Top flight boxer.
So for him to knock him out,
of course it was just,
he's so good man.
So for him to do it accidentally makes complete total sense.
Well look at the GS.
Yeah,
that guy is a beast man.
That's like a legit top flight boxer.
So he's in there even just accidentally getting punched in the face by,
and that's what I want to see the movie.
I'll tell you that Michael Jordan talking shit to recover and get back to
training and,
and,
and filming after that.
It's like you never be in the heavyweight class.
You never saw abs until the movies.
You never,
it was always like,
I know.
Right.
You know,
they were like,
they were like basically punching bags,
you know,
so now,
now it's like they have to be so Tyson,
you saw abs when it came out of prison.
I remember that.
I guess so when you fought Peter McNeely,
dude,
he was prison jacked.
That was like maybe the scariest Tyson ever.
Like they finally released him and all you've been doing in jail,
I don't think he could box in jail.
So I think he was just lifting weights.
You remember he was super duper jacked when he got out of jail.
Let me see.
Can I see a picture?
He was,
yeah.
See,
go to Tyson.
This is Pete.
Yeah,
that's Tyson versus Peter McNeely.
That was in 1995 he looks good there.
It's terrifying.
That was the most terrifying movie Tyson ever.
He just looked like he was made out of steel.
Just a tank of a man.
And I'll never forget the fucking way in or the stare down rather cause during
the steer down,
Peter McNeely signed up for that fight knowing that he's a tough guy who's going
to take a fucking vicious beating.
That's what he signed up for.
He knew what he was doing.
He knew he was gonna give it his all.
But he knew that if you had a bet,
most people were not betting on Peter McNeil.
Yeah,
but you could see it in Tyson's face when he's staring him down.
There's this crazy,
he's following him everywhere.
He goes like a Predator dude.
It's like a Predator who can't wait to get the green light to let the genie out
of the bottle.
Watch this.
This is Tysons first fight like look,
see Peter mcneilly's kind of looking down and you look over tie,
so we'll get his eyes.
Dad Is fucking terrifying if you're looking at that and you know
he's smiling and trying to like,
he's trying to like make light of it.
Oh my God.
And he looks just like a prison guard dude.
He is easy.
Oh yeah,
he does same hair.
That's really guard here.
After the Trump [inaudible] hair,
I sat next to me,
sat next to Tyson at after that at the Charlie Sheen roast and made a lot of
jokes about him and a afterwards dice call me.
I didn't really know dice at the time.
He'd call me like a couple of weeks later.
He's like Java to dice.
He's like,
he's like,
he's like basically said that he couldn't believe I said those things to Mike
Tyson and like he was offended and I go,
what do you mean?
Whoa,
whoa.
He's like,
do you have any idea what that animal could have done to you two feet away?
And then we've been friends ever since,
but I didn't think,
I didn't think about Tyson.
He seemed like a pussy cat at the time.
At the time.
But if that was Tyson from like 1986 I think if I watched an old fight,
yeah.
By the end of the night,
I'm literally like laughing and it was lap.
Well one,
he loved it.
Yeah.
He loves,
you can take jokes.
He could take jokes.
Oh yeah,
but you wouldn't want to be doing that.
Imagine if I said I don't want to Piss you off,
Mike.
If you would do that to your face,
imagine what you would do to mind.
He's basically the only celebrity to ever pull off a face mask,
right face.
I thought no one else has done it.
What?
Celebrity feud?
Charles Manson.
Well,
those,
those mumble rapper dude's yeah,
postman alone type characters to cal.
She's 69 but he was the first.